I want to clarify some
of the terminology I used
in the last video.
But before I do that, let's just
make sure that we understand
the mechanism of how
arteries can get blocked.
So in the last video, we talked
about these plaques forming.
And if this plaque is unstable,
at some point it could rupture.
And when it ruptures,
this material
can start to flow out
into the bloodstream.
And two things will happen.
I just want to make it
a little bit more clear
relative to the last
video, especially now
that I can zoom in
on these arteries.
Two things could happen.
Plaques-- or I should say
clotting, not plaques.
These are the plaques
that have been released.
The clotting factors can kind
of clot these released pieces
from the plaque.
And the other thing
that can and often will
happen-- and I didn't
talk about this in depth
in the last video--
is that you an also
have-- when this
thing ruptures, you
can also blood clots form here.
Let me do this in a
more reddish color.
So you can also have blood clots
form on the ruptured plaque.
So everything, even
the plaque, the part
of the plaque that
has not begun to move,
can experience clotting.
And also the part
of the plaque that's
kind of been dumped into the
bloodstream can also clot.
In the last video, we saw
that one of these clots
can go downstream to some point
where the arteries get narrow
enough so that they
actually block the artery
right over here, and that
just restricts the blood flow.
So now all of a
sudden, you don't
have any blood flow
going downstream.
And all of this muscle
tissue that needs the blood
flow from this point, that
needs to get oxygen from that,
it might die.
And you might have a myocardial
infarction or a heart attack.
Now, what I want to clarify
is the actual terminology.
I guess, I was a little bit
hand-wavy with the terminology.
I want to get a little
bit deeper here.
This actual clot that forms that
can restrict the blood vessel,
this right here is a thrombus.
Thrombosis is the process
of a thrombus forming,
so thrombosis are
these blood clots
that form that can
actually help to kind
of obstruct a blood vessel.
So this thrombus
right here is actually
going to make it
harder for the blood
to flow through this vessel.
Now, any of these
released pieces or chunks
in any of these
blood vessels that
can float around and
eventually lodge themselves
in and eventually
block the blood flow,
these are called emboli.
Or if I just use them in
the singular, one of these
is an embolus.
And I want to be clear.
An embolus is the
general term for anything
that can float
around in your blood
and eventually lodge
itself, at some point,
in your circulatory system
and restrict the blood flow.
What we drew in the last
video-- and in particular,
this one as well-- is that
these emboli that are also
clotted-- so they're also
kind of thrombus-- they're are
thrombi and emboli
at the same time.
This right here would be
called a thromboembolus.
These words are strange
to say sometimes.
So it wouldn't be wrong
to call it an embolus.
But in particular, when we
say it's a thromboembolus,
you know that it's kind
of this clotted material
around this release plaque
that can go lodge itself.
And in the last video, I
called this a thrombosis.
But that was really
not quite right.
The thrombosis is
really the formation
of the clot that can
restrict the blood flow.
When it actually
lodges itself further,
when it actually breaks
off, becomes an embolus,
and lodges itself further
often restricts blood flow,
this is called a
thromboembolism.
Let me write this.
So hopefully I'm not
confusing you too much.
These medical terms
confuse me a lot,
but I want to make
it very clear.
Thrombosis is just
the general formation
of a blood clot inside
of a blood vessel
that can restrict
the flow of blood.
So this right here, this
is thrombosis occurring.
That is thrombosis.
Once things break off and
they start floating around,
they're an embolus.
That's the general term for it.
And in particular,
if it's broken off
material that is due to a
clot, it's a thromboembolus.
So thromboemboluses
are a more specific way
of calling it an embolus.
And once one of these things
lodge themselves and block
the blood flow, that's
a thromboembolism.
You can also call
that an embolism.
Just when you say it's
a thromboembolism,
it makes it a little
bit more specific
to know that it's kind
of clotted material.
So hopefully that
clarifies things
and doesn't confuse
you too much.